I wanted to ask you about that most of
our NATO allies now seem to have made a
comment about whether or not they want
to send tanks to uh to Ukraine why is
Canada so reluctant to explain what we
want to do on that front
well let me just start by saying that
Canada is
absolutely committed to supporting
Ukraine and we're going to be with the
people of Ukraine for as long as it
takes
and as finance minister
let me also add that I really believe
that a clear
strategically viable and stable
Ukrainian Victory this year would be a
big boost for the global economy and a
big boost for Canada and I say that
because I think it's important for us as
Canadians to understand we're supporting
Ukraine because it's the right thing to
do
because the Brave and really smart
resistance of the people of Ukraine I
think has earned the admiration of the
whole world
but we are also supporting Ukraine
because it is in our national interest
to do so
I'd also like to
remind people that on the financial
front Canada is on a per capita basis
one of the leading supporters of Ukraine
and that economic Battlefield is a very
important one
helping the Ukrainian government to be
viable every day to pay pensions to
ukrainians to literally keep the lights
on is important and we're there Canada
is also a very important military
partner for Ukraine my colleague Anita
Anand who is here and with whom I've
spoken about this today and yesterday
and with the Prime Minister has said
that everything is on the table when it
comes to supporting Ukraine administer
Anand recently announced 200 Rochelle's
going to Ukraine and we are going to
continue supporting Ukraine because
that's the right thing to do